[Music]
well someone's having a good week and
it's only Monday there was no collusion
with Russia
there was no obstruction and none
whatsoever and it was a complete and
total exoneration this was an illegal
takedown that failed and hopefully
somebody's going to be looking at the
other side hmm
thank God the media saw this coming can
I hear an if true report that if true
meant that federal investigators had
evidence that the president United
States committed a serious crime and
potentially an impeachable offense true
would confirm part of the steel dossier
which alleges that Cohen then met in
Prague with powerful Kremlin figure
systemic collusion between the Trump
campaign and Russia to tip the election
and Donald Trump favored with money
changing hands left and right and lots
of meetings if that is true you know
that's a enormous incomprehensibly big
deal how do you explain the Manta Ford
allegations as anything but collusion
there was no collusion on his part
tonight I can tell you that maybe the
most suspicious denial we've heard yet I
think they're shocked that the noose is
tightening that people might go to jail
you're exactly right their lives if true
yeah about that collusion in other words
as the president has insisted from the
start there was no collusion so this
indicates the President on collusion it
does a lot of smoke about Russian
collusion but no fire 500 search
warrants 50 pen registers we learned
today found no evidence of conspiracy by
Donald Trump in anyone around him that's
a huge deal a huge win for the president
hello nine-one-one I'd like to report a
death it's the mainstream media finally
choking on their own lies now this
should be a victory lap but if I were
the president I'd be ticked off despite
the relief that vindication brings it
won't undo the harmful crap the country
went through thanks to a media who
pushed this hallucination
they cobbled together a tail with
weightless words like if true and
sources say built with junk terms
spouted by junk analysts all drunk on
their need for post 2016 revenge and we
had to play along
because skepticism about collusion was
portrayed by the media as aiding Trump
meanwhile at CNN they wonder has Russia
coverage helped or hurt the news media's
reputation that's like a sloppy drunk
wondering has my drinking helped or hurt
my reputation especially when respected
reporters pronounce this story worse
than Watergate what we are watching in
the Trump presidency is worse than
Watergate I've said before that what
we're seeing is worse than Watergate
because in Watergate the system work
know the only thing worse than Watergate
was their lie that it was worse than
Watergate by the way it wasn't
commentators like us who pushed this but
so-called analysts reporters and experts
when Trump said fake news was the enemy
of the people
boy did they prove him right but it
wasn't just about him it was about you
about dividing us conflict as a business
model Smollett Cavanaugh Covington now
collusion the hits keep coming in the
media never learns
so the steel dossier was fake the leaks
were fake the physis system abuse and
the media dragged our country through
this BS it's not Trump that Russia
snagged its a bunch of useful idiots
called the press all right Jesse I'm
gonna hand over the rest of the show to
you I'm going to the bar to celebrate
I'll be right there
felt like election night all over again
no collusion no obstruction Juan you
don't have to say anything I accept your
poverty party hats I would wear them
maybe a cake and Putin can jump this was
a knockout punch to the mainstream media
I don't think they're ever going to
recover from it their credibility is
completely shot millions of Americans
will never take them seriously ever
again they booked their shows full of
fools a roster of fools they have to let
their contracts expire and put him out
to pasture it was all a bunch of boys
who cried wolf and they never booked the
other side there's a big shift in the
media now taking place CNN
see see they dug their own grave through
hate and greed and now their ratings are
gonna soften Fox News ratings will take
a pop and that's because we had the
story right from the jump and it wasn't
just the opinion people like Hannity and
Sarah Carter and Dan van Juneau and greg
jarrett the hard news side nailed it
down to of catherine herridge bret baier
and john roberts and our dot-com people
because we were the only ones that
followed the FISA abuse the dossier the
Peter Strock and all those text messages
we follow the truth and we were
suspicious and we were proven right now
President as you said called the media
fake news because they gave aid and
comfort to the enemy
it wasn't donald trump who was the
traitor the traitors were inside our own
government and vada mere Putin has to
look back at the last two years and say
thanks Democrats you basically made
Russia look stronger and divided the
country and look at how they brainwash
the country 44% say the Trump campaign
colluded with Russia
52% think Trump tried to interfere with
the Muller investigation flat-out not
true and if you criticize the media and
said they were fake news they said oh my
gosh you're attacking the First
Amendment you're attacking the freedom
of the press
great permission to make an analogy sure
the media is the dossier the media is
fake smears bought and paid for by the
Democratic Party and so instead of doing
an autopsy on themselves you know what
they're doing what they're saying you
know what Trump has showed little
interest in healing or national unity
that's they're pivoting Martha what will
the media ever reflect on these mistakes
that they're making and follow our lead
in our example as objective doesn't seem
to be much much capitulation what's
understanding about what just happened
what they have just witnessed because
they've immediately spent most of the
day I was watching other channels in my
office throughout the day most of it on
this little opening for obstruction of
justice
yeah this potential that maybe there's
some avenue for recovery that perhaps
there was obstruction of justice and you
know it really strikes me is that if
anyone thinks that that the new Attorney
General
released this summary without a very
clear feeling that it accurately
reflected what was in the larger report
that they're all screaming for full
disclosure on and I think we all want to
see it of course we want to see it I
think that they may turn out to be sadly
mistaken no - I just loved watching them
shove brian Stelter through that small
hole of obstruction trying to get the
guy to get him through all right all
right one I know this is hard for you
yes I mean it's it's like it's you know
first you got you defeat Isis on Friday
collusion gone Aven Eddie's in prison
this has got to kill you yeah some
believers like they built the wall they
have you know I mean the Chinese deal is
done good news you know first of all I
think it's good news that the president
was not that's true found inspired me
well I think it's good news yeah that
Robert Muller was able to conduct a
nonpartisan probe and come to
conclusions and I think most the
American people can trust mm-hmm I think
the bad news on that stunt is that he
confirmed Russia interfered in the 2016
election to help Donald Trump and there
from what we know Trump you know like
well if that's happening he didn't tell
the FBI he kind of welcomed it but he
apparently and none of the people
directly around and was found to be in
conspiracy with the Russians but the FBI
didn't tell him that they knew that that
was happening
no they suspected it they kept him from
knowing that so how would he have done
anything to stop it
well I think that he could have
acknowledged because remember Martha he
had meetings right here at Trump Tower
his sons having meetings with Russian
officials I get don't forget he then
goes on I mean he says setup at this
point okay whatever you want to say I'm
just no he welcomes Russian officials
into his campaign office and then
secondly he's standing there Martha next
to Vladimir Putin and says oh you know
American intelligence that said Russia
interfered man I believe you not my
intelligence officials or how about the
law how about the business about oh yeah
I wasn't doing any business with Russia
during the campaign obviously we know
not true but that's true we know that
but I want to bring day9 cause we've got
to detain a
all of these experts have so much egg on
their face they could open a Denny's
yet there's still as Jesse said we'll be
invited back on to shows to pontificate
okay because they they express the
perfect anti Trump Trump sentiment so
you will still see David Frum and Bill
Kristol the contortions will be very
interesting to watch over the next
little bit too since he like well
actually I still could be true to
Martha's point like if we get there but
if we get that document it will be
interesting to me to see remember after
the 2016 election a lot of reporters
went out on the road in America to find
out why did we get the story so wrong
right we miss it how did we and they've
now we've had books have even been
written about how did the media miss
this yeah they might do it here as well
but I will just remind you just from a
personal anecdote going back to the
special prosecutor of the Valerie Plame
issue with Karl Rove he knew for a year
that he was not going to be indicted but
because of the rules he was not allowed
to say anything the stress the agony of
what you put people through with these
special prosecutions is it's definitely
going to have to be looked at not just
by our government but by our media
mm-hmm I hope that we all agree though
the reports should be released because I
think Republicans and Democrats want to
see it just get it out there all right
well we're going to talk about this some
more it's a day of reckoning for
everyone